- My name is Michaela Coel.
I write television and act in television
and produce television.
The first script I wrote was a play
and I did that in Drama School
we were in our final year and they do
all these really big shows,
these big kind of period dramas
and I felt like none of those shows
were representing me as a person
and I knew that I wouldn't really
be cast in any of those when I left school
so I decided to take
myself out of one of those
plays and write my own
kind of one woman show,
and that was called Chewing Gum Dreams.
And so I did that and that was my
first kind of way into writing.
(upbeat music)
I've been quite lucky because I kind of
had a massive big break with my play, but
it's not very easy.
Also, people create parts,
and you can't just decide
you're going to go and get a part,
you have to audition, you
have to even get in the room.
It's very hard to even get an audition
so that can be very hard.
But overall I guess me personally
the challenges are not getting tired,
not burning out, I work
very intensely when I write.
I write for two days
with zero sleep, zero nap
and that can be very
draining so it's kind of
about trying to stay healthy with that.
I never decided I want to be a writer.
A very kind of unusual
story, for five years
I was a really devout
christian, and the first day
I converted to really very
Evangelical, Pentecostal
Christianity I was given a bible
and the bible had psalms and proverbs
and that's when I started writing poetry.
Then went around performing poetry
and there was a director in the audience
and he said you should try acting.
So I did, and that was in 2009.
So it's all just kind of happened.
Where do I find time to write
and then be in other people's shows?
I guess I've been quite
lucky with my schedule.
So next year I won't really
do much writing at all,
it's just going to be
acting the whole year.
This year has been very heavy on writing
and acting really.
You just make it work.
I think if you really want
to do it you make it work.